A fruit-based vegan diet is a diet without any animal products whatsoever...
...and consisting of mainly fruit.
900 calories of sugar excellence.
My name is Mikkel and this is my brother Mads; we're from Norway...
...and we eat more fruit in a day than most people do in a month.
We tend to rely heavily on bananas.
So this will probably last us a couple of days.
Every day, I probably go through 15 bananas, maybe 20; it depends on my activity level.
Whether it be a banana or a mango or anything else,...
...every fruit tends to have every single nutrient in different balances.
In my opinion, the ideal diet consists of mainly tropical fruits.
I feel amazing when I'm eating fruit.
I'm actually more satisfied in terms of taste and gustatory experience...
...than I've ever been in my life.
For me, it's not really about an ideology.
It's not really about a religious belief.
What matters more is that we found it and we tried it,...
...and once we tried it, the results spoke for themselves.